here to dig into this a little further
is editor-in-chief of The Daily wire and
host of the Ben Shapiro show Ben Shapiro
Ben I know you were hoping for a more
muscular ly conservative pic like Amy
Kony Barrett but how does Kavanagh sit
with you now well I think that he's a
stand-up double not a homerun and then
that's basically what I said during the
deliberations and I've continued to say
that now that that he's been picked the
the reason being not because he's not
conservative enough I really don't see
conservative as a great descriptor of
these judges but because he's not
originalist enough in the sense that
he's not going to overturn I think wides
slash swats of precedent that actually
need to be overturned where I think
Coneybear probably would have it seems
to me that he's much more of a judicial
minimalist in the mold of Justice
Roberts that in all likelihood he will
gradually pair back decisions that he
thinks are bad as opposed to making kind
of broad muscular decisions that you
would see I don't say a Thomas or a
Scalia or even a Glory such I mean I had
I take your point I had I Adam David
French on just yesterday who did
describe him as an originalist tell me
why you disagree he's definitely an
originalist in the sense that he reads
the text the way it was supposed to be
written the problem is that this is
moderated by his belief in number one
precedent and number two a degree of
gradualism with regard to his
interpretation of the law so whenever
you see a case you can determine whether
the case is constitutional or not on one
of two grounds the broadest possible
grounds or the narrowest possible ground
so to take a perfect example the
masterpiece cake shop case could have
been decided on one of two grounds is a
religious Baker who is basically being
fined by the government for not catering
a same-sex wedding the court could have
said that we are striking down any law
forcing a religious Baker to cater a
same-sex wedding that's religiously
discriminatory or they could have
decided it on the much narrower grounds
that in this particular case the
Colorado Civil Rights Commission was
especially mean to the brewer religious
Baker and therefore in this particular
case this was unconstitutional well the
court decided to decide it on the narrow
grounds and have some pretty dramatic
ramifications because if they decided on
the broad grounds then obviously anytime
there's an attempt to pass an
anti-discrimination law it would run
afoul of the broader decision it seems
to me that Cavanaugh is is more like
Roberts in that he would probably try to
decide these things on narrow grounds as
opposed to broader grounds okay thanks
here's vice-president Mike Pence
yesterday with
- take a listen what the president was
looking for here was a nominee who will
respect the Constitution as written who
will faithfully uphold the Constitution
in all of his interpretations of the law
well I do but I haven't been nominated
to the Supreme Court so if you want Roe
overturned you say Cavanaugh is not the
guy that's gonna do it I think that's
right I think the most likely scenario
is that Cavanaugh and Roberts form the
sort of minimalist swing set on the on
the Supreme Court remember it takes for
votes on the Supreme Court to even
countenance a case on writ of certiorari
so let's say that Montana for example
decides to pass a law that bans abortion
across the board except in cases of life
of the mother being endangered and it
goes to an appeals court the appeals
court rules along the lines of roe v
wade well then that case gets appealed
to the Supreme Court it takes four votes
for the Supreme Court even to hear that
case I don't think have-nots and Roberts
mode to hear that case I think instead
they just reject that case and instead
maybe they take another case like a
fetal heartbeat case or a fetal pain
case and they gradually pare back sort
of the legacy of Roe as opposed to
overthrowing it all at once so what can
conservatives look forward to with
Kavanagh on the bench well I think that
he is going to rule the right way on a
lot of these cases I just think that
it's gonna be a lot more gradual than
they would want it to be in cases like
Roe versus white they can also count on
the fact that he's very much against the
administrative state so he's a big
proponent of overthrowing what's called
Chevron deference which is this belief
that administrative agencies get to
essentially adjudicate their own rules
that if you run afoul the EPA the EPA
gets to decide whether you ran afoul of
the EPA and the judiciary has nothing to
say about that he's very strong on an
administrative rule and separation of
powers he's also very strong on the
second amendment so in a case on remand
in DC versus Heller he stood up for the
idea that assault rifles bans assault
weapons bans were basically
unconstitutional in those two areas
where he's particularly strong well I
have you before we go I gotta ask you
about this tweet from Nehru let came up
today it says we'll be damned if we're
gonna let five men including some frat
boy named Brett strip us of our hard-won
bodily autonomy and reproductive rights
thoughts well
one I would remind them that it was
seven white men who decided that roe v
wade had to be enshrined into law in the
first place second of all I'm not sure
where they're getting that Brett
Kavanaugh a religious Catholic who
coaches his daughter's basketball team
and gives out soup at the soup kitchen
in his spare time is a frat boy but I
guess if you want to look like a sexist
that's a pretty good way to do it yeah
not not the bet not the best line of
attack but uh here we are Ben thanks for
coming on I appreciate it
thanks a lot